democracia obstruida por la oposición el
portavoz del gobierno
se posicionó así sobre el rechazo del
parlamento francés al artículo segundo
de la controversial Reforma pensional se
proponía la creación de un índice de
personas mayores esto en el marco del
paquete completo de la Reforma para
Elevar a 64 años la edad de retiro
lo digo yo este voto es incomprensible
es meramente político y demuestra que el
objetivo de los opositores no es vencer
al desempleo sino derrocar al gobierno
uno de los argumentos de Emanuel macron
para defender la reforma pensional es su
Victoria en las elecciones
presidenciales del año pasado el
presidente defiende que la gente votó
por su proyecto democráticamente y que
la reforma era parte de este desde el
inicio pero el discurso actual parece
contradictorio previo a la elección de
2022 pidió el apoyo del pueblo aunque no
creyeran totalmente en sus propuestas
sola en el moho no invito solemnemente a
nuestros conciudadanos cualquiera que
sean sus elecciones en la primera vuelta
a que se unan con nosotros algunos lo
harán para bloquear a la extrema derecha
y soy consciente de que eso no merecerá
el apoyo del proyecto que llevo pero lo
respeto
el posicionamiento actual del presidente
ha causado revuelo en la ciudadanía y
este jueves 16 de febrero hay un nuevo
llamado a protestar contra la reforma
las pensiones Francia tiene un régimen
semipresidencialista lo que genera
contrapesos entre el presidente y el
parlamento
la asamblea nacional está constituida
por 577 diputados elegidos directamente
que se encargan de discutir y aprobar
iniciativas de ley por lo que la
democracia en el país galo tiene muchas
máscaras que la del presidente